[Musique]
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation les plaisirs 5 minutes
séparent feront bienvenue à ce tout
premier gala qui récompense le cinéma
québécois 1 le premier de toute la vie
on n'a jamais eu avant
en fait il y en avait un en avant c'est
juste que ça non non non non il y avait
débat animé dimanche au studio 42 de
radio canada
le gala québec cinéma avec guylaine
tremblay rien de moins rien de moins
quel genre de défi ça représente pour
toi mais là l'an 2 le défi c'est d'être
à la hauteur des attentes
l'an passé on était on était nouvelle
team bon fraîcheur du mois il y avait
plein de nouvelles choses l'an passé ni
votre film le larbin s'est acheté un kit
de cette année c'est d'être à la hauteur
des attentes
quand on est entouré d'acteurs il ya des
vieux amis qui ont des nouveaux visages
des inscrits a vraiment permis de te
démarquer c'est ton sens de l'humour de
la répartie ça vient d'où cette alors
c'est très dur a dit moi quand j'ai
regardé encore une fois je parle elle
est nue mais quand j'ai regardé pour la
première fois dans mon sous-sol en
abitibi quand j'avais 8 ans la lni j'ai
vraiment été interpellés comme jamais si
jamais quand je regardais les olympiques
ou n'importe quoi d'autre je me dis h
ferait bien de la ringuette jamais je me
suis donné la lni et quelque chose en
moi qui faisais ah oui ça c'est moi
comment on fait pour aller le ch capable
je me sentais totalement capable
mais sur une patinoire ou sur une scène
c'est là que je me sens totalement ce
moment et je veux parler des enfants de
la télé
ce défi à peu près possible de remplacer
antoine bertrand
ouais comment ça s'est passé est ce que
monsieur a donné quelques conseils à
madame
en fait c'est drôle comment ça s'est
passé
d'abord on m'a demandé d'auditionner
pour remplacer verrou j'ai d'abord
refusé parce que ce n'est pas remplacé
verrou d'en vivre parce que ça c'est un
peu comme quoi mais bon
plusieurs téléphones quand même à mon
agence oui on aimerait ça qui est dit
donne moi alors je me retrouve sur la
chaise de véro avec antoine bertrand qui
est là pour donner la réplique sur le
plateau loti avec vos spectateurs mais
quand même un espèce de vraiment une
audition mais dans le dk et moi je me
trouve totalement imposteur et je lui
dis d'ailleurs hey
bonjour ça pas de bon sens bienvenue aux
enfants de la télé je joue le jeu je ne
peux pas croire que je suis verrou du
tout et pendant les extraits sont
antoine bertrand qui est un site qui
fait des cinq soirées 6,6 me fait des
signes de souhaite à ma place moi je
comprends pas parce que se prononcer que
sans vote et par après j'ai compris que
je pense que fait un pli les producteurs
avaient un peu en tête qu'il fallait
aussi remplacer antoine pis que c'était
pour ceux qui voulaient me voir à
l'oeuvre
sarr a d'ailleurs assisté récemment
image labeler je vois pas de quoi tu pas
ses tarifs de prendre des notes de
regarder deux animateurs et de matrix
pour dire assez stable truc ce jeu
pourrait l'appliquer dans votre avis -
l'âge et regarde tellement pas la tenir
alors opposé
non j'y vais avec un instinct avec car
je suis avide de commentaires quand même
à chaque fois je dirais si vous avez des
as face et des trucs qui marchent pas si
oh vraiment au producteur est elle
attendue ce jeu j'écoute beaucoup ce
qu'on dit mais je pense que j'y vois
instinctivement l'époque j'allais me
faire coiffer le tout les belges à
l'aube a dit que puisque depuis un
moment donné j'avais plus à deux
salariés vous restiez en jaquette
je vais demander un pote bertrand je les
applique quand j'ai su que je le faisais
je dis ils viennent on va aller prendre
un café quelque chose dont on se
connaissait pas vraiment puis très
gentille et est venue avec moi honte à
aller prendre un café puis grosso modo
ce qui m'avait dit seuil soit ce soit
toi même plausible peu de préparer un
peu mais c'est quand même 60 % de
l'intro et de la spontanéité effet coeur
président turc souvent défrayé les
manchettes pour tes enfants de trois
enfants c'est capoté parce qu'on essaie
d'aider protéger d épargne et de tous on
les met pas à l'avant mais je pense que
trois enfants pensent que 6 fois la
norme puis peut-être que les gens et les
gens et se demande un peu comment
comment on fait trois enfants travailler
autant on se partage beaucoup on a
beaucoup le nez dans vos agendas
alors nos moments d'intimité se passe
beaucoup le nez dans la ged afin de
mettre ces coiffes et préoccupe la
semaine prochaine fois qu'on ait
beaucoup là dedans quand un accepte un
truc l'autre restent disponibles pour
les enfants
ces messieurs accueillez-vous d'animatis
guylaine tremblay alors qu'est ce qu'on
souhaite pour dimanche pour le gala
québec seulement c'est d'être vraiment
un moment présent comme on le fait l'an
passé puis l'an passé j'avais secret
gitans 16
alors je le disais personnes j'avais
caché sa sous marins de cette année tout
le monde le sait programme et je vais
aller tu es souvent j'aurai une grande
robe je vais à l'été fait que ça viendra
le moment
et rappelez vous que si un producteur à
lui même à la dose plus facilement
utiliser le trophée thomas romain bonnes
fights
[Applaudissements]